What we have seen so far are the basic features of Acme. That is the vocabulary
of keywords and descriptions that you can build from the keywords describing
basic architectures. However, Acme has some additional features that allow you
to go beyond this basic vocabulary. In particular, because Acme was
designed in support of interchanging architectural descriptions between tools.
And each tool may have its own vocabulary that goes beyond what's needed for
simple interchange. Acme has a mechanism for embedding within it tool specific
terminology. This additional text is not interpreted by Acme other than for
syntax checking. But is passed along to the various tools. And they can do their
own work on it. This extension mechanism is called Acme's property sublanguage.